I have such a great documentary
recommendation for you today it's called
sour grapes it's on Netflix it's the
story of a young wine savant who cool
conned wine enthusiasts including a coke
brother out of millions of dollars it's
a story about this guy here who you see
if you're watching along with me
Rudy karna Wan who was a rich
20-something year old dude who started
rubbing elbows with big wine
connoisseurs and buyers and ended up
perpetrating a major wine scam and the
documentary is so well done I don't want
to say too much more because I don't
want to give away a lot of what's in
there but you have footage of a lot of
these scams being perpetrated you have
footage of what law enforcement
ultimately saw when they got involved in
what was going on here and you also have
really good interviews including with a
coke brother who is actually a victim of
the scam that Rudy Qurna Wan perpetrated
so I haven't seen this documentary so I
think I can speculate a little bit
because he just take cheap wine pretty
much like a step up from box wine and
bottle it up in these nice bottles and
then sell it for a lot more money than
it's worth not exactly I mean there's a
wine counterfeiting angle to it but the
really sort of sophisticated part is
actually manipulating supply and demand
initially to then be able to better
profit from the wine counterfeiting part
I mean it's a really involved scamp yeah
I'll have to check that out that's
absolutely it's called sour grapes you
can check it out on Netflix and of
course you can check out a list of all
of my recommendations this includes
nonfiction books
fiction books documentaries websites
newsletters all sorts of stuff at david
pakman.com slash recommendations we have
a great show for you today we're going
to be taking some audience phone calls
after the break I've got a great classic
interview for you we have also three
audience questions that we'll be
answering a little more extensively at
the end of the show so I'm glad you're
with us on this Friday david pakman.com
slash membership to sign up for member
support the work that we're doing if the
normal membership rates are high we've
got a solution for you
it's called coupon code I voted
seventeen use the coupon code
I voted seventeen when you sign up and
you will get a major discount off of
your membership will take a break send
me your thoughts about any of today's
stories on Twitter at de Pakman